hello welcome to
to our program
uh
you see
uh we bout that you see
uh christina ricci is on the podcast
today on our audio
delivery that's coming at you from the
the the through the wooden box radio
thing
sorry you guys we're just i know you
guys want intros and you want us to tell
you who's on the podcast and i
i don't understand why because there's
google
and it just confuses me so much why i
have to say tell you that christina who
christina ricci is like i just i don't
get why that's so hard
for some of you guys um but it is a good
opportunity to tell you that i am
florida i'm coming to your state and
coral springs florida i don't know what
that means
or where that is it's basically miami
fort lauderdale for la dee da
i love fort lauderdale um i've made a
lot of mistakes there
uh one time i went on vacation there
with my dad and there was a dead fish on
the beach and i was so sad that i tried
to revive it by um
like
making it like
slapping it on top of the ocean it
didn't work and i learned a valuable
lesson that day in fort lauderdale
and
i like the humidity in fort lauderdale
it's good for your skin
and but it's basically miami also the
other thing about miami is
there aren't a lot of like stand-up
venues there so
last time i was there y'all party hard
in miami you do not play around
and i got humbled last time i was
performing in florida last year two
years ago
why do comics always say like last year
yesterday last night like let's be
honest you know when a comedian does
like a set and they're like so yesterday
i saw this thing yesterday i saw this
thing you're like you had a busy day
yesterday
like whoa that was wild you went through
a breakup and dropped your kid off at
school and went home for thanksgiving
all in one day
um
where am i going with this
the point is
florida i'm in miami y'all party
normally the show times are
7 p.m
and like
9 30 p.m in miami the first show is
always at 9 00 pm
on a weekend
and
you know i usually go to florida
when i'm about to shoot a special
because you know florida is just a great
indication of what is funny when you're
doing stand-up because it's like
you know you guys are like you have a
good sense of humor smart you can take a
joke whatever last stop gonna go to the
beach get some sun get tan look cute
shoot special and i go down and there's
these um
girls in the audience
you know it's like
nine o'clock show drink a champagne
they're in their sequiny dresses their
bbs and their arden b and their bandage
dresses and their handkerchief tops
and
they're filming me while i'm on stage
and i'm like it's a it's a tricky
situation when you're being filmed
because you're like i want you like i
want you to enjoy the show every time
but i also like i don't want you to put
stuff out
on youtube that other people can see
because then i'm
look like a hack
and i'm still working it out it might
not be ready yet and so i finally had to
say something i was like girls i love
you so much thank you for coming to the
show but can you please stop filming and
they looked at me and they were like
grace the fact that grace managed
to sneeze
right at the perfect time
where i was going to crescendo
that story
is truly unbelievable this is this is a
girl that is allergic to not being the
center of attention this is someone who
physically sneezes
when someone else has the limelight
this
grace is someone who is
allergic to someone else being funnier
than her
so has to sneeze
great timing though by the way a great
comedic
timing
i don't know how to even get back on
track for that
sorry christina ricci's publicists um i
know you're listening to this and you're
just like why like should i just go to
law school
should i just go to albuquerque and make
soap yep you should and meth
and
get a chia pet call it a day
so
so i'm like
like
really not wanting
to
call these girls out that are having so
much fun because they're filming me
because i'm like oh they're tagging me
they're filming me like that this is the
new no the new world like this is what
we do and i was like you guys can you
guys just not film me while i'm doing
stand up i just i don't want it to get
online and then i
then it's gonna ruin the special and
they looked at me and they're like
we're
filming ourselves like they were taking
selfies it wasn't of me it was of
themselves
i
i made the grave mistake of thinking
that
i was the celebrity in the room
and when in fact it was them
um so that's south florida for you
[Laughter]
come to my show so that you can document
yourself watching me do stand up
and send me that footage because i need
some reaction shots
we're gonna go to orlando hard rock cafe
which is in orlando am i doing comedy
cafes still
i feel like i've worked really really
hard i'm at a point where i can't do
comedy in any more cafes
i do open mics and cafes but it's a hard
rock let's just call the hard rock
orlando florida november 13th royal oak
i'm coming at you hard royal oak music
theater
first show there are some tickets the
other one sold out here's the thing
about sold out shows
a lot of people
this is cracks me up
okay so
you guys bought these tickets like two
years ago a lot of people are not coming
because they're like hey i bought these
tickets but like i don't live there
anymore
people have moved they're like weren't
i'm like we don't live in more local
anymore
my uncle like i had to move to spain to
deal with my uncle's estate
like i know there was a woman who was
like sorry i couldn't make your show
i bought the tickets when i was single
for a couple of my girlfriends and now i
have two kids
[Laughter]
so these rescheduling shows has been a
little bit of a a little bit squirrely
um
because
uh
of all the rescheduling so
so
we were in also when we were in atlanta
last week the braves won so there's a
braves parade and all these people
bought tickets it was sold out venue but
then there were all these like there
were some empty seats and then i was
like what's going on why like did i
thought we sold the show out why didn't
we
and then people were like oh sorry
couldn't make the show bought tickets at
the braves parade like rolled my ankle
drunk on the side like people just
so come even if you even if it's sold
out come because there will be empty
seats
um
due to
all sorts of unforeseen
circumstances
i'm going back to wisconsin
on november 19th love you guys oh yes i
that's where i puked up all those cheese
curds
the other day i lied on the floor for
between 15 and 45 minutes
such a weird window of time i had to
take a cold shower before i got on the
show because i
i took a spirit airlines flight
grace
we need to talk
and i
vomited
i thought i had covered
and i ate so many cheese curds that i
threw up into the toilet
wisconsin
november 20th i'm going to be in
minneapolis uh at the pantages theater
there's a second show was added
december 3rd boise i'm going to be at
the egyptian theater is that racist
at all we're allowed to say egyptian
theater okay
walk like an egyptian one of my favorite
songs not gonna sing it not gonna dance
to it december 4th seattle washington
neptune theater we added a show we sold
out so fast but like don't we sold it
out so long ago that don't forget that
you got your tickets you don't like
people might re-buy tickets at this
point like it's just like people are
like oh hey i forgot that i had tickets
to this already i bought another set of
tickets and then i found them in my
dresser drawers
december 9th and julian davidson who is
this woman oh my god i can't like i just
the fact this joanne davidson in
columbus ohio the fact that the theaters
are named after the people that paid
money to put their name on the theater
like do you really want your name on
this like you don't know who's coming
after you i don't want to buy a theater
and then it's like
i don't know
you know what i mean why put your name
on a theater who cares for what joanne
you we have to talk
december 10th i'm in cleveland at the
agora theater simple clean
december 11th i'm in chicago at the vic
theatre there's a second show in chicago
chai chai let's talk
plus we just were announcing just now
that i'm going to be in las vegas
in january
look at me win las vegas steve wynn do
you know that he has an assistant sorry
i love the story you know what i
he is okay so steve nguyen
this is a rumor which means it's true
that steve nguyen has someone christina
ricci is coming up don't worry don't
panic don't be mad
um scroll scroll forward if you want
after hosting wendy williams i'm full
chaos
i'm into the chaos i'm like just leave
it in dude i got a wendy williams
wormhole of her going like sipping the
tea her tea going is this the same tea
bag from like she's like we're watching
it looks like a rehearsal i want the
podcast to feel like
does she know she's that we're rolling
that's the kind of energy i'm into
20 22. okay so steve nguyen
is
going blind
steve nguyen brilliant seems like a nice
guy
and
billionaire has money and he's got
somebody
who's an assistant
whose only job is to push his cups
only job is to push his cups
back onto the table when he places them
like half off the table
so he has someone this has to be a video
now because look he goes he'll be like
anyway so i just bought this van gogh
and someone just goes
someone's only job like the guy in
succession like the tall guy like its
only job
is to just make shit
is to just make sure
that he scooches he's the scoocher he's
the guy that scooches the cup from here
to there whoop
it's that guy what do you do for a
living i scooch steve wins mug
every now and then i just scooch steve
wins mug because he's going blind he's
got a billion dollars but he can't see
so every time he puts down his mug i got
a scoot
he just follows him around and does it
like what is he right when he goes to
the doctor and it says occupation
ladies and gentlemen
i'm at the wynn las vegas
and if you work for steve wynn i'd love
to meet you
and i i aspire to have somebody
that scooches my coffee cup when i
put it on a table in a tilted way
because i'm that rich and blind and lost
as i'm
showing you a tour of my collection
wednesday 11 10 10 a.m
code touch
i don't understand any of these codes
what are these fucking pre-sale codes i
know you guys are smart you guys are
smarter than me so you tell me
you just get tickets you know what to do
we got this
sorry about all the codes
add to cart
just
i don't know
january 15th see you there
my mom's birthday's the 13th so i'll be
in great shape
christina ricci
[Music]
so this is a
this was a dress that i bent and cut
into a shirt
that i love
i noticed you do a lot of cutting right
before you do things which
i mean would make me so nervous i
but it always seems to work out so it's
okay right don't have children
i don't
i mean that would make me nervous before
i had children i don't know
i just feel like when you don't have
children you can act like a child maybe
no but i just mean in terms of like what
if you cut it and it unravels while
you're on air or something
great okay oh no i guess everything is
uh
yep i saw you put those on the other day
and i was like it's come off so easy my
press-on nails are about to come off
what do you do in this situation i think
it's about to do anything this to me is
kind of like almost see you how many
months pregnant are you i'm almost nine
months not
nine months almost i'm 34 weeks so i'm
like two technically two weeks away from
nine months but i like to round up
because it makes me feel better i love
that like
as soon as you're a pregnant woman you
have to be amazing at math it's like 92
weeks well people try to trick you and
you're like no i it's ten months of
pregnancy i don't care what you you're
saying with this night ten right it's
not
40 weeks is ten months so why do we say
nine months i don't know
so from conception
to
burst yep
national explosion
what is what is the time it's 10 months
total it's 10 months it's 40 weeks
i feel like there's a lot of things
we've heard in movies that have misled
us
into
how childbirth is supposed to go you
know we spend a lot of time talking
about how like movies set these
unrealistic expectations for women and
relationships how about childbirth yeah
a friend of mine when she had her first
baby she was like i thought my water was
gonna break
and explode not only like ten percent of
women's water actually breaks yeah then
have you seen the videos where they like
pierce it
no i am not on that pornhub
they show you i mean they show you live
births and they like encourage you to
see live births and
my first pregnancy i wanted to be really
prepared for every horrific outcome so
that i could manage my feelings ahead of
time
so they tell you like you know after you
give birth
you might
look at your vagina with a mirror and
don't be upset
and so
i
was horrified when i read that and then
i googled images and it's
wow
it's intense i was really happy i had a
c-section
you're first yeah and
did that happen
planned or unplanned no and at the time
i was annoyed
because like i lived in brooklyn and
williamsburg and it was like a big deal
it's like what's your birth plan and i
never
i was always like my birth plan is i'm
going to do whatever the doctor tells me
exactly i'm definitely getting paid meds
yeah um
but it was very popular to have a doula
and to have natural births and all this
stuff which i wasn't excited about but i
kind of got into this idea that
i wanted to have a vaginal delivery
just because it's very anticlimactic to
like go through all this and then not
have the water break oh i'm in labor
rushing to the hospital thing
and i
felt i guess i wanted that experience um
but then my doctor
wanted to
schedule my delivery because she wanted
to give me a c-section in front of
students
which i didn't know there would be
students involved until right before
then i called the hospital to ask them
to please not allow her to have like
students
i just was like i can't i mean
i don't want people talking about seeing
my insights later you know what i mean
you know
it's a little different when you're did
you do like a discount no
and they lied and they said they
wouldn't and then
i was completely like numbed up and
lying down and then they brought in the
students
to watch you
get cut open and have my baby taken out
of my insides
yeah yeah so i didn't really want the
c-section but i had to she told me to
that i wasn't the kind of person who was
going to go into labor and
she would she refused to induce me if
she told the hospital not to induce me
they wouldn't
and
i also didn't want to have a i didn't
want to go into labor not be able to
deliver the child and then have a tired
doctor perform the c-section on my child
she was like you don't want a tired
doctor developing um performing your
c-section
which i took
man made the baby
i just i took that as a threat so i was
like great we're just having a c-section
and afterwards i was fine i mean
afterwards i was like you know what
i didn't destroy my vagina
i have this small scar
i was fine afterwards the baby was
head was shaped nicely so i was just
like all in all this has worked out
great so i'm fine with it even though i
didn't enjoy the way we got to c-section
and people in my neighborhood wouldn't
talk to me they said i should have
gotten a doula and fought i was like
fucked i'm not gonna fight anyone and i
fought fought
i was like me and the doula are you know
just your sex dream like mud wrestle you
want us to get in a thing of jello and
fight i should have gotten a doula and
fought for my baby
i was like well i mean i don't know
maybe the doctor's right and i should
have a c-section maybe it's more than
just
i don't know i'm
not a mother
uh to
infants
some i am to some i've raised a couple
men in my day
a couple boyfriends
um but i feel like you know i did date a
pediatric anesthesiologist and he
you know i always like to stay in my
lane around the motherhood stuff
and he was like the number one
way we see babies perish is coming in is
babies is people that want to have home
births
well that's my thing i would never do a
home birth just because i feel like it's
valuable to have the emergency room
ready use the technology yes i usually
take no judgment towards anyone who
wants to do whatever
but for me personally i have way too
much anxiety it's also this it's like
when you go to the hospital are you
riding a horse are you driving a car
you're driving a car yeah so when you
get there
get the epidural if you need it you know
his whole thing is like epidural says i
want it to be natural like the best
thing for you i don't know
about the progress i know that's how i
feel too like maybe i'm one of those
women that would have died in childbirth
so maybe the c-section um is great for
me
do you know what i mean like maybe this
this progress is really
helping me how's the second pregnancy
been different than the first um i've
been a lot less swollen which is hard to
believe looking at me but you look
amazing no i'm really really but it's
like natural fill like it is it is
actually quite a lot of filling out and
puffing it's like awkward because you
look so young and you're pregnant
you look like a child right like you're
like a 12 year old pregnant girl i just
saw jowls earlier on my face and i was
like oh but i did this thing today that
i think is a good tip
my face has been so swollen i froze my
face mask and put it on my face frozen
game changer oh yeah i had a giant again
i have a jawline today because of the
face and you put it in the freezer and
then you put it on for how long well it
was still all crispy just the normal
amount of time that it would normally be
on my face i feel like when we first
started texting it was about skin it was
it was about natural answer
i'm obsessed with all those lasers and
everything and i cannot wait to go back
and get my face laser to every three
months laser laser laser um so yeah we
were texting about like skin care stuff
you are probably
the
paragon
of skin do porcelain
i don't think so i've seen really good
skin in my life i'm just saying but i
would say you are iconic your skin is
iconic okay is that what paragon
is that what all that meant sorry excuse
me um
yeah i mean people do assume i have
porcelain like you're like a doll you
have a doll face like poreless i don't
think in real life i do but i think that
that is something that people do to
images of me quite frequently
hmm and when i was younger registering
your skin what do i do to my skin
well when i was younger when i was 20
and botox became
popular i was like well i want to smoke
cigarettes and not take care of my skin
and drink and stay up late so i'm going
to freeze this
and it'll be great later
and it worked out it was good it was a
good move this is a strong choice on my
part
nailed it yeah i lost a lot of i love
choices in their 20s
i lost some parts because i couldn't
emote properly i think
oh my god i've so done that yeah gotten
the botox gone in the audition and been
like oh i'm so scared yeah oh i'm so
scared my forehead's not moving but i
promise i'm scared i didn't do myself
any favors in that department but it was
fine it's fine projection is god's
protection
exactly
um well i did that but then i do really
enjoy the lasers at the doctor's office
but i feel like the lasers the ipl's the
ones that just like burn off the top
layer of your face
they take they um
the hair follicles die so you start to
get really shiny
wait well you have to do it in a way
where you don't end up looking like a
burn victim corrupt yes it's really like
a burn victim's skin afterwards there
was a um remember krista smith she's now
at um
netflix was she she was at vanity fair
she's the west coast editor and she was
working on a story about just sort of
botox
faces etc and said something interesting
she said wrinkles are now a sign of
youth
because you're too young to have had
anything done yet or more wrinkles or
side of you i don't understand how this
is possible because like when you're all
the older you are the less wrinkles you
have yeah yeah yeah exactly so yeah so
if you're 25 you have wrinkles i have
noticed that they have like smile lines
yes totally we're afraid of yeah
terrified it's just like so brave you
have that in your face totally like dude
25 year olds you're like dude hey
benjamin button
what's wrong like she needs some like
what's going on you need some centrum
silver like 25 year olds look older than
50 year olds at this point
which is fascinating true i have stopped
with all the botox and everything and i
just do the
laser treatments lasers skin what's your
favorite skin
i do um lancer method and 111 skin 111
oh yeah that's my favorite oh that's
fancy yes the masks are so yummy
delicia haas
so i have a
document i have a document
for christina ricci look what it says
will you just read that for everyone
oh okay
don't say um and don't interrupt
i did notes to myself oh i thought those
were for me because i do that all the
time okay for me oh okay don't say um
and don't interrupt well i will try not
to say i'm or interrupt i want to talk
about yellow jackets
this is a show you're doing on showtime
i'm
an addict everyone knows this i identify
as an addict
and
i'm so annoyed that i've only seen three
episodes after seeing three i was like
angry
on this podcast we have a little bit of
a illegitimate issue
benton
yeah we have this ongoing
saying around here to watch out for them
yellowjackets
because
one time whitney had company over uh her
friend nick and he was going to go out
in the yard and and it was the summer
and she just out of nowhere ran to the
door and she went hi nick watch out for
them yellow chickens
were they south african yellow jackets
and she was very nervous about it and we
were all just taken aback so now it's
become this like slogan that people will
scream at us to watch out for your
legitimacy
the amount of people that have dm'd us
the billboard
wild oh that's so funny
so we have this weird odd connection
with yellow jackets anyway because
yellow jackets the bug they are assholes
yeah they are yellow jackets
kill bees yes i'm a bee person i love
bees she's made of them i'm made of bees
um and i
you know i have a whole bee thing like i
have a water trough out for them like
trying to save the bees the whole thing
but i have uh yellow jackets that come
in and they
kill my bees and they fight but it's
very hard to tell the difference
sometimes and then i'll break up fights
between yellow jackets and bees i mean
how do you do that how yeah
i'm just like i know with dogs and you
spray water at them
it's called mental illness
and it will you just get in there and
wave your hands yeah i get my little
press on nails which are popping off
like right now oh god it's just possible
and i just like don't get in between
um
so yeah yellow jackets there were so
many reasons i wanted to watch this show
i
was in nashville with kesha doing the
that show the uh spooky show she's uh
keshe was doing a show about like
haunted
like um penitentiary haunted places and
like having these sort of mediums come
and and i was watching it and i i stayed
up till three in the morning i could not
stop watching it i was a possessed oh
good i'm glad
you know you work on something but then
you don't know if people you know you
can't tell if it's good or not really
yeah it's probably so hard to like get
distance from it it was just like i was
it was like get this in my veins oh
that's good i was obviously i wish it
was like one of those shows where they
dump it all at once then not like
no i think this is good i think it's
good because
the
antici like anticipation and the tension
of waiting for the next i think is a
good thing okay good yeah and i like
that i like breaking it down i'm very
addicted to like i feel like this is
going to be yellowjackets is going to be
like the walking dead or something where
you're like i need to talk about what
this means and what the symbolizes and
napoleon what if this soccer player is
you know what i mean like it's just so
intense i have a question about that um
do you feel like extra pressure when you
do uh
shows and movies and stuff because
literally every character you played is
like so iconic do you feel like
extra pressure to like i gotta do i
gotta give another one another
i don't feel like that but i feel like
but but thank you um i feel more like i
just want to do really well so that
it propels me onto the next thing
very like straightforward like i i know
when i get fired i want to be used and i
want to make the most of that out of
this opportunity like it's very mundane
my approach to everything
healthy it's very healthy
so
but it is fun but i do have this weird
thing when like
maybe it's ego maybe it's um egotistic
but i never want to do anything that
anyone else has done before
so every time i create a character
i have this problem with where people
are like well what is that or like um
the eps or creatives or directors will
be like i don't know what that is i
don't recognize that and i'm like yeah
that's why it's good like we gotta yeah
yeah let's do that that's good but
people don't like that so it's really
sometimes difficult
yeah no
but i do have so maybe that's sort of
more like where
that kind of
iconic thing maybe it comes from is that
i'm always trying to do something that
you haven't seen before yeah apply makes
uh
a more fun challenge too so you're not
getting boxed into something else has
done before i find it really
boring well you're very good at that
you're such a weirdo well people people
don't like it they're like well i don't
understand what that is it's not
relatable
i don't recognize that expression
you're like this is the uncanny valley
but then you'll be like but there's a
line that tells you how i feel so what
is my why why do i have to double tap
this and you're also like look at my
track record but i don't know
about that
it's really amazing
interesting i also
the way that we met
we've met i feel like we've known each
other for many past lives yeah when i
was doing all my press for pan am you
were doing all the press for the whitney
show whoa
and we had
we had crossover publicists
that's true
so i remember from that we would always
be like now that you'd be in one
dressing room and i'd be in another okay
i blacked out all that out i see i
remember that that's wild
um and i
basically like
i just feel like we have this i don't
know we know each other really really
well and on a very like deep level
um
but
i hadn't seen a lot of like i haven't
seen you like on talk shows i haven't
seen your appearances like i haven't
seen that stuff you know and i was um
before you came on i was watching some
of your talk show appearances
are terrible it's comfortable
what really people are so weird with men
are so weird with you
really
like
i was watching something on comic con
people like asking you questions and
you're just so
grounded and normal
and it's so clear that so many men have
such an
intense attachment to you and like
they're just awkward with you
okay maybe that is what it i don't know
what it is i always feel like i just
don't respond the way people want me to
that's that's really just where i took
that like
it's just you're not corny
yeah i have a lot of trouble with like i
told you my dream podcast is like party
pooper this is a good thing tell me
about this idea i love it i want to do a
podcast where it's where i'm either it's
either like something the party pooper
or like changed my mind or called change
my mind where because
we do a game called blow my mind oh it's
just like blow my mind blow my mind tell
me something i don't know well this one
would be
i because the idea for the podcast is
that all i do is disparage things that
people love like tick-tock
for adults driving precious things yes
yeah and just like point out why things
are lame that people are really into
and then
you can't just you can't just have a
show where that's all you do is trash
stuff so i'd have people like the
biggest tick tock star and i'd like
change my mind tell me why they said i
should like you valid and you shouldn't
just be totally ashamed of yourself
right
because i feel like that would be a
great show i would listen to that i
would listen to that make me
like you
yeah make me understand make me make
management because there have been
things that people have changed my mind
about and i've been like oh okay i see
that i got it i missed it now i get it
yeah yeah i get it now yeah but i better
but i do have like an allergy to
like corny cheesy and i also feel like
sometimes i can tell what people want
from me and i just refuse to give it to
them
is horrible and like so teeny it's not
it's so like you're the original
like authentic
like
a jerk
it's not it's like the original it's you
know sheryl sandberg all that like lean
in stuff it's like lean out
you're the opposite you're like you know
and i i really do like i i'm very
uncomfortable with being too accessible
i think it's because i'm small
i don't feel that's the real thing yeah
that's very real i don't like being
likable i don't like playing likeable
characters i don't want people to
identify with me i feel like
because i i think that through life i've
learned that people will
covet and
claim and try to control
and it's and so i'd rather be i'd rather
people were afraid of me but what's
hilarious is that nobody is nobody is
afraid of me
everyone's like you're five foot two
we're going to touch you all over
and tell you how cute you are and
now you're pregnant so everyone's like
what is it with when you're pregnant
people just can your public property
i don't really know i mean people like
to touch your belly which
it's like nothing to feel
it's not there's nothing going on
nothing exciting going on there guys
that is interesting there's such a deep
biological basis for
the trauma of being 5-2
yeah well it's you know it's very sad
physicality is fate
so yeah and that like you have to be
smarter because you have to be hyper
vigilant because you can't necessarily
reach the fruit you can't necessarily
reach i can't defend myself physically
and nobody's afraid of me and
i mean i try to be a little bit more
intimidating but i'm just not apparently
it doesn't it just doesn't work
um so and you're dismissible because
you're small
that's interesting i i have a the
therapist that i uh work with she's like
a addiction trauma
therapist and uh emdr type thing and she
whenever i'm like having an issue with
somebody who's being very aggressive
with me like a woman
because that's my main struggle now is
like kind of sort of when you come from
like borderline personality disorder and
the family
home and alcoholism it's like in you
know women there's this very exciting
moment where it's like women are bosses
now yes it's like whoa like we don't
have a lot of practice like being bosses
to each other and what's the difference
between boss and bitch and being direct
and being a cunt and me you know
and um are we allowed to be friends in
the workplace but like what was that
supposed to mean like it's just we give
us a second to grow our sea legs here um
so she'll always ask me if i'm like this
woman is like really being aggressive
with me and she's like
you know
she always will ask how how tall is she
and i'm like five five four and she'll
be like yeah of course
yeah you know she has to yeah make up
for life make up for it you know what i
mean yeah like if any if i want anyone
to take me seriously i have to be so
extra cold
and aloof and unfriendly the second i'm
like all friendly people are like
just like oh get away from me sorry i
was nice to you i'm not a garden gnome
yeah it's really
it's pretty interesting but yeah
so
um
your dad
was a primal screen therapist yeah my
dad had a mini cult
cool yeah i guess
i mean yeah in theory
it's exciting
yeah he was a primal stream therapist
he basically like many cult leaders
uh kind of roamed through his early uh
years
with like weird odd jobs you know like a
parole officer and you showed her a cook
and like a cook in the army like weird
stuff like that
and then found i don't really know how
but he kind of um
he at the in the 70s when like everybody
was getting very into like other people
telling them what to do and who to be
and all that stuff he was like i can do
this
and so he started a group therapy
um thing practice called the center for
emotional re-education
and it was um
they had you know it was like a meeting
with a circle in chairs and people would
role play and scream and you weren't
allowed to look him in the eye or talk
to him until he started session
and my mom told me about her first time
that she went and um
and uh yeah they just
went on and then he ended up moving the
whole group because he they ended up
like following him and worshipping him
and stuff and i'm sure he was just like
oh my god amazing i can really i would
like to join this worked out better than
i thought no eye contact i'm in and so
he brought everyone to la
and he ended up doing it out here
and getting involved in some other stuff
and then this is how scientology started
yeah
um but it was but
and then he's then he kind of it all
collapsed when colts became less popular
and uh he ended up becoming a lawyer
and some other stuff late in life that's
incredible but he would still have for
extra cash um
prime screen therapy meetings in our
basement which was not fully um
soundproofed
and so i would go to bed like 10 o'clock
at night as a child and hear them
screaming from downstairs like i hate
him why because he's an asshole
be specific
you fucked my best friend
so that kind of thing
and then in the morning i'd come down
and like six o'clock for school and i
would imitate reenact everything i heard
from my mother who thought it was just
the funniest thing she'd ever seen in
her life
because she thought the whole thing was
so dumb
question do you think that that him
having a cult following affected
your view on why you don't want to play
likeable characters you don't like this
like because you kind of have your own
little like cult following among like
you know like hot topic kids and like
that community so like does that affect
like with you being like okay don't
worship me like i'm a person too do you
feel like that an effect on that or
because you watched someone be like
no because by the time i came around
like it all fell apart when i was two
and then there were these
evening sessions that i would hear
um
i don't know i mean maybe because my dad
wanted to be like so badly i it turned
me off to people wanting to be liked
that much um interesting i could just be
projecting an entire no no no no
it's totally possible
i mean it's a valid point
that's fascinating and like i just i'm
just thinking about like you know
because
i was so reluctant to even
do this with you because i was like i
want to be your real friend i want to be
friends with you i like you but i feel
like when you are an
actor from an early age like so many
people want so much from you i don't
want to be one of those people that's
like taking from you you know yeah and
then i was thinking about
that and
and i was like you know what we were
talking about last night with the man of
knox right uh that like i still haven't
figured out a way to articulate it but
that
i think that
when we say like child actors like
that's so crazy i think that's the
perfect time to start acting because
you're already in an
imaginary yeah
you can do the acting but not be
explained for the same it's the same
part it's interviews it's
people talking about the way you look
it's all that's it's the fame really
that i think is not good for for young
people because you should develop who
you are
before you present that to the world
that's interesting because otherwise
people are just constantly telling you
who you are who you are right that's
confusing yeah but i mean it's it feels
like you know
you were a i just feel like it's much
weirder to start acting at like
when you've already become a
human in the world and you know how
reality works and then you're like i
want to be a liar well maybe i don't
know i didn't have that experience yeah
like i feel like it i feel like you
nailed it
i feel like it's the healthiest
situation possible
maybe i had a lot of trouble though in
my 20s and stuff
adjusting yeah yeah in like late teens
i did not like being famous no
why
she's too too like i don't know i felt
it it was all very invasive
and you know people have so many
opinions about you and i don't know it's
hard not to like take them as the
constructive criticism so then you're
always trying to change and please and
that kind of stuff
something i'm obsessed with you about is
like
why do you think
and i know you curate the roles that you
take so you know carefully but like
what have you learned from the
characters you have played like it's
it's it's you like to play to see do
things that no one's ever done
which i love and then you're going into
like you know whether it's drug
addiction or sex addiction or these like
really dark places or playing lizzie
borden like what have you learned about
human nature from having to like enter
into those like really dark spaces
i think i just
have really i mean it just reinforces
this whole idea that like it's gray
nothing's black and white people are so
complicated and and that there are no
i mean i hate to say i do sometimes feel
like there are bad people but
it's
they're
it's just not black and white good
people can do bad things yes and
and it's just
complicated and our idea of what's good
changes all the time and
yeah i think that's more than it more
than anything just it's really opened my
eyes up to the
vast variety of human beings because you
have to empathize with these people that
have done despicable things and you have
to you have to find a way in of being on
lizzie borden for example being on her
side you know like it's like okay
you can also judge them at the same time
i can be like this is a fucking terrible
person i'm playing but yeah this is why
she's doing that but this is why she's
doing it and
she because i think for the most part
right when
you know like lizzie borden i was
binging the lizzie borden series that
you did
so camp
i loved it it's so good
it's very campy though
but in the perfect place yeah
as it should be
it's the perfect tone it's the perfect
tone
knows what it is knows what it's doing
you can't really take it seriously
because
that would be strange yes but it's
exactly it's um
and it was but it was
the perfect tone that's all i'll say and
um
what like what do you think about like
when you're like doing like the
murdering stuff like that it's camping
and funny you're like this is funny and
i'm just gonna i don't have to really
like go there go there but i'm just
gonna yeah because it's you know you
take in the tone of whatever show it is
you're doing and
you know if you keep that spirit alive
then it's okay so like with lizzie
borden it was just like this is so camp
and so
it's just pure
fun because lizzie borden was and what
there's a couple little i'm obsessed
with just in general like female
murderers and our obsession with female
murderers like
was what do you believe that she
i don't know i mean he was motivated by
it's fun to think that she actually did
it
but when you really start getting into
it doesn't really seem like she did it
yeah
because the whole idea that she had no
blood in her clothing because she took
her clothes off and committed this very
salacious crime completely naked
you know it just feels very much
and it was it was the victorian age
when you read the whole the whole all of
it together you're sort of like oh
somebody just somebody really fucked her
over
yes and i just loved like the leaning
into it on the of that the character
when you played lizzie borden was like
she kind of knew she was accused of this
thing and used it in ways to sort of get
what you wanted like a crazy person like
i love that yeah you know
and um
uh but the lesbian dalliance i feel like
was very
played up too
yeah i mean they wanted a lot of they
wanted it to have more sexuality to it
and i don't like that kind of stuff yeah
i don't like doing it so
you know the so
i was sort of more open to
them i don't know it's these two it's
more comfortable to do that with women
that's like great sure take her a
lesbian throw some ladies at me that's
fine
um i'm obsessed with lizzie borden she
was involved in christian organizations
and she was uh
she left thirty thousand dollars
equivalent to six hundred thousand
dollars in 2020 to the fall river animal
rescue league yeah she liked animals
yep
which is so fascinating because normally
the telltale sign of a future serial
killer is someone that abuses animals
i'm not so sure that she did this as i'm
saying yeah that's where i get
there were a lot of like you know you
know how they have this whole thing
where a lot of crimes are not solved
because we refuse to believe in the
randomness of a stranger killing you
know they always look for someone who
had a connection yes well there were a
lot of like there were vagrants in the
area one one in particular
he had
weird issues with business um
businessmen in the area
it seems like it was this vagrant
who had bothered who'd like come to the
house earlier and sort of bothered them
and it seems more like it was that guy
but it's a more
sexy story if you had to beat lizzie it
was more fun was that like the first
amanda knox okay we're doing justice for
lizzie with our new movement hey was
lizzie borden like amanda knox before
amanda knox kind of
i don't i like i said i don't really
know her whole story i met an accident
falsely accused though yes yes yes
exactly but it was like
it was a very similar thing there was
like someone in the area it was more fun
to accuse her it was like she's sexy
she's beautiful she's young like this is
a way better story it's going to sell
more papers it's so that is yeah and
that is what happened with lizzie borden
it was like one of the first tabloid
cases
wow
because the printing press had just
started making newspapers
um
i'm
obsessed with my incredibly intellectual
history
you know can we just talk about
murderers for a second yes okay so
female murderers
um uh sorry your i know your publicists
are watching um they know about my the
only thing the only problem the only
thing advantageous for some people for
you to be the only advice i've ever
given
is is and this started back in my
twenties when i go to a photo shoot they
would be like do do not cry and do not
get naked on camera honey
but not cry because i was like upset
i cried once in a photograph and all
these people really liked it so then
after that every time i would go to a
photo shoot for editorial or whatever
they would have me cry and they were
like eventually people think there's
something wrong with you
why did you cry the original time
because they were like it'll be a cool
photo and it was
it's a really good picture
obsessed with you
um that's
yeah stressful
no but i'm just saying that's the only
thing that the you can
suggest that i play murders elizabeth
bathory
do you know this story the countess yes
and she that she was i read this book
that was released about her back in 19
like i don't know if it was the 90s or
maybe the 2000s but the blood queen yes
this hungarian woman which is
fascinating because it's now there's
lots of links to like the current
conspiracy theory of like q anon q
anon's whole you know the conspiracy
that they believe we eat babies they eat
babies in hollywood that's exactly right
it's eating those babies it's so wild i
have put placenta on my eyes but that's
for bovine it's bovine placenta i would
also
was do you remember when there was that
that serum that you could buy larger
beauty supplies
and it was
supposed to be from the foreskins of
babies
it smelled like blood
this is why we're in this predicament in
the first place
yes
i get why
uh actress is talking on ellen about
their skincare routine plus a little
weed plus a couple sam adams equals
killing babies to look young
it's um
it's a tricky one uh
because i do the i have colostrum and
placenta
from biologique or cherish or cherish
that brand yes and they're but they're
bovine i believe okay yeah just eating
just using baby cats
i'm not killing babies to stay young i'm
killing cow babies to stay young you
know it's like still
probably bizarre but um i had someone
come up with gene airport we were in i
think it was in san antonio this group
of kids came out today and they're like
oh my gosh you're ready gummies hi oh my
god and they're like um
we hear that you
kill babies and put stop it stop it
not the right on your face not really to
stay young
no i was like
then why are you talking to me yeah they
must not actually believe it you can't
belie tell me like you must not believe
it if you're saying that to me you know
what i'm saying it was just such a
that's very strange i feel like
we're at an impasse here yeah
that also thank you
and then they offered her a baby
this is mine i don't want to raise it i
know i'm like all the women i know in
hollywood are having fertility struggles
and
would kill a human for a baby not a baby
to look young
you know what i mean
it's so hard to get a baby anyway
at our age
um
but there's some interesting links
between bathory and cunanan it came from
a prominent noble family in hungary
sources say she convinced her husband to
build a torture chamber
in the castle they shared she's said to
have killed over 600 girls right you had
bathed in the blood of virgins yes
apparently but then they believe
that all these stories were there was um
like another faction that wanted to come
in and rule and take the throne away
from her and so just like um just like
um oh god what is the name of the we can
go the um
so there's a
an emperor nero so all the rumors about
nero apparently it's a similar kind of
thing where it's all um um
what's it called i have baby brain so
mom brain yeah when babies probably
again like all propaganda to change the
views you know to to get the people on
their side and against these people
apparently a lot of it was campaigning
against her and making her look bad so
that people would help them overthrow
her because she was overthrown
ooh
so this could be like a conspiracy
yeah just shit they said about her that
wasn't true yeah a lot of people say we
named the bathroom after her too
bathroom bathroom oh bathroom oh
interesting
oh that's uh is that you that twin i
read oh really it could be a lie but i
did read it and then um okay well andrea
yates houston woman accused of killing
her five children oh yeah i remember
that's right 2001. well they kept making
her have kids and she already had
terrible postpartum yeah
that was postpartum psychosis as a
mother as a mother now and having one
what
i had an experience where a girlfriend
of mine
we didn't talk for like two years
she just
dropped off the face of the earth i i
was like oh she's having a baby like i
guess she's busy whatever and then she
calls me and gives me this like
apologies i'm so sorry i was so mad at
you and like i didn't even know it was
happening it's like i had such bad
postpartum
and that's when i really started
i didn't even know really what was
happening but like what is the
current um
new new in terms of postpartum is there
a plan for it how do you diagnose it i
don't know i had invasive thoughts after
my baby um of like people and children
being tortured like horrible invasive
thoughts and then um i went to see a
therapist like a year or two later and
she said oh that sounds like you were
experiencing postpartum but i just dealt
with it
yeah i have that too when i'm like um
amanda knox is staying with me and her
babies and when when i see a baby my
brain goes like don't drop it don't drop
it and i imagine dropping it yeah i'll
imagine all the horrible things that i
had a really hard time my baby because
you know they can't lift their heads
they can't defend themselves in any way
and i kept having horrible invasive
thoughts about babies being tortured
like i i get the same thing and i'm like
it's in nightmares like nightmares serve
a purpose like our dream server purpose
it's like our brain preparing for
possible future scenarios yeah you know
that could happen yeah and you know
practicing preparing
and um
rehashing and so i was like okay i guess
this is happening but since she's been
staying with me there's a baby staying
in the house and i'm like
the dog could do that like it's
nightmares about the baby being
smothered me rolling over on it me like
all the things
i could do bad late and i'm like am i a
psychopath or i think it's just my brain
trying to not do those things yeah
that's kind of what i thought it was too
trying to make me more protective of the
baby yeah but so when um
yeah just like exploring all the
possible scenarios so that you don't do
those things you know
it's not like bad thoughts it's like
these are good thoughts because they're
telling you what not not to do or what
is possible
um
leandra
cnc
children i don't know her she
uh after a series of miscarriages and a
fortune teller's prophecy that her
children were at risk she decided that
she needed us to sacrifice other
people in order to save them over the
course of the year of
1939-1940 in coriggio italy she killed
three women and disposed of the bodies
she used caustic soda to disintegrate
the bodies and according to her court
testimony she turned one of the women's
remains into soap which earned her the
nickname
lasap
the soap maker okay so she made soap out
of three women
how do you make soap out of dead people
why is that and like how do you know
you're clean what how do you clean up
they shouldn't even enter bubbles what
they should have nicknamed her bubbles
that's so much easier to say
this is like a soap opera
um
i just there's something fascinating
about
like
when men are serial killer male serial
killers we think they're like ha
ted bundy like zac efron plays ted bundy
i'm not into it i don't like it
like the bunny tapes come out like
that's hot like he loved her so much he
had to kill her and then i don't like it
and then if a woman is a serial killer
everyone's like
see
we knew it
pms bitches be crazy
i just think it seems even crazier when
women do it because we're just really
used to women being you know
stereotypically nurturing i'm just like
also more like
what woman has time
it seems like strange impulse i don't
know
i but i don't i really don't i mean i'm
fascinated by serial killers but only
because i want to figure out like how
they got into people's houses so they
can never get into mine
that's sort of my motivation
i facetimed you ambushed you yes uh i
was in bed i was getting ready to go to
sleep i looked horrible i'm so sorry no
you're fine because i should not no no
not at all i mean what's wrong with me
that i'm like great i'll just accept
this space-time call
it's weirder than me facetiming you
accept it
yes i know
i know
i think that's how that was going to go
i know i don't know what's wrong with me
sometimes they don't think about things
yeah the bachelorette was on and she
said her uh first like erotic that was
the best that was the bachelorette can
you remember afterwards what you said
what you said about her
and she was talking about casper
and
what like i i don't you've talked about
it too much already but where do you
fall in terms of paranormal activity i
believe in ghosts
i mean i don't really know
what else i mean but i do believe like
are ghosts having sex with us right now
no i really don't want to believe in
ghost rape
you know about that actress that went in
this scan you know they do that think
it's scared you can do go and like
promote your show by being honored it's
scared
to savannah you know savannah oh yeah
yeah and apparently a snowman actress
went and um
i thought i think she like wouldn't go
to the ceremony the next the night after
the night in the hotel because she
claimed she'd been raped by ghosts
which i know is horrible but that i'm
laughing but time's up ghost
anyway
believe women
i have had that experience though where
i'm like i know it's haunted in here and
please just don't rate me yes well i
just i'm
because i did this thing uh where we
went ghost hunting and i'm there was a
rem pod there was uh all the ways you
communicate with ghost i just feel like
because you did that movie you probably
have a
uh
an abnormal amount of
you sort of incoming energy about that
world i don't know i mean i've had
things happen to me in hotel rooms and
places and like abandoned insane asylums
and stuff like that that
abandoned insane asylums oh you know
yeah there's this one in vancouver where
everyone shoots
and we shot some
yellow jackets in there and but then 20
years earlier i shot some of this other
movie in there and feet chased me down
the stairs like a disembodied
shoes
not great no it wasn't good it wasn't a
great it wasn't harvey weinstein did not
want to be there anymore and then so
that did you hear it yes and then i
turned around and it was like one of
those staircases where there's like a
wall in the middle and you like come
down and go down
and as i looked around the corner there
were these two black
shoes coming down after me
it was not a good feeling i saw i
remember
i still don't know how to tell the story
because i was like i don't i believe in
ghosts i guess
but i
i don't say that i believe in one ghost
because the one i saw right i believe in
a ghost the ghost i met
i don't know about all your other ghosts
i don't know about them like i don't i
need to see your papers
but
uh
when i was a kid i had um some
childhood
that was not ideal some negative
attention from an older man when i was a
kid and
i was in west virginia
and i was scared and i came out of the
hallway of this very old house in west
virginia and i was jumped out of bed
to try to get away from this person and
i went the hallway and i saw
an older woman in a nightgown like a
like a long nightgown that was like very
lacy like it was like eight o'clock at
night
on a weekday it wasn't like a dress it
was a nightgown like yeah when you wore
gowns you know
and
she told me to come towards her
put pointed me into a direction where my
aunt was who was the safest person for
me and i just ran in there and then that
was it
that's kind of amazing
i thought so yeah like guardian angel
something helpful ghost and i'm like
helpful ghost i'm like is that
like a figment of my imagination is that
a trauma response whatever it was like
it felt very real to me yeah yeah i mean
who knows but still sounds like you're
describing martha stewart a little bit
it is tilda swinton oh well she is
that's great where you make my healthful
ghost a felon
a criminal
that doesn't pay
taxes okay first of all we love martha i
love martha too we're standing she paid
taxes she insider traded oh right yeah
right
you know how you do it too i am
heartbroken to tell you we are going to
take a quick quick hiatus
from the dazzling gorgeous hilarious
incisive christina ricci you need a
break it's overwhelming right you're
gonna get overwhelmed you're gonna be
enamored
we need to take a minute because we need
to talk about refueling we need to just
regroup
okay we need to talk about daily harvest
because this is this is a product that
has truly changed my life
changed my life because i i'm sorry i i
can't do the ordering meal service stuff
all the time from it's ridiculous it's
too expensive like to just or you know
and then going to get something i also
don't have time to cook during the days
like what are we amish like i can't put
a healthy meal together on my own right
neither i also if i go to the grocery
store to try to be healthy right i just
i get distracted i just come home with
five bags of seeds and like olives
i forget the butter i forget the kale i
don't know what's in season yeah this is
the first time you've ever had real food
in your fridge i've known you by the way
it's not just like salsa and pico de
gallo i know that i used to only like
eat because i thought like salsas just
was i was like okay this is a lot of
different colored vegetables this looks
healthy
and i would just eat it was like i was
always eating gazpacho i was just eating
salsa like i didn't it wasn't gazpacho
it was salsa it was salty i know but if
it's cold it's gazpacho
and so this like daily harvest has
changed my life you know that women get
half their calories from salad dressing
i did know that it's pure sugar so i
would get salads and i would think it
would be all healthy and then i was like
why do i have a headache why am i so
tired like
so daily harvest you know that we love
these the bowls are a game changer i
just put a little little oil in them a
little water put them in the uh and
that's cooking to me you don't even need
to do that no and then sometimes i put
some extra hot sauce i put my fancy i
put my nutritional yeast flakes on top
if i want to you're like gordon ramsay
benton you love this flatbreads i
thought i love the flatbreads and the
bars
you like the balls what's the best it's
all healthy we don't have to go to the
farmer's market we don't have to like
and they're already in a cup the lid is
a cup you just put a straw in it and all
organic right to your door normally to
go organic you have to drive two hours
to a farm and and break over a barbed
wire fence and steal from a farmer daily
harvest offers delicious harvest bowls
slap bread smoothies and more all built
on organic fruits and vegetables right
to your door daily harvest takes
literally minutes to prepare and never
uses preservatives added sugar or
artificial anything and that goes for
everything my personal daily harvest
fall favorite is the broccoli cheese
bowl oh
yeah i love it i'm very passionate about
it it's sad it's so good i love it
sometimes i'll do a little chip and eat
it like a dip
like soups and soups like somebody's
somebody has to really fix you yeah but
this is this is my favorite the kale and
sweet potato flatbread it is like so
good tastes like fall
it does taste like fall dailyharvest.com
good for you to get up to 40 off your
first box that's dailyharvest.com good
for you up to 40 off your first box
dailyharvest.com
good for
you
now
uh speaking of good for you
um
i just got a stitch fix box special
delivery here's what i'll say we've been
touring on the road a lot of our fans
that come to the shows they wear stitch
fix and they call themselves stitchers
that's cute which is yeah they call
themselves stitches
so i am now officially a stitch stitcher
but there's a new uh because i can't
shop for myself if i'm left to my own
devices i'm just going to buy like
vintage yellow
labrador
vests and i've seen the pictures i'm
wearing a t-shirt
with david bowie and uh megan connolly
on it it's teenage
bride before i knew she was 15 and he
was 39 when they shot the movie you
bought it in the 90s
so it was before i knew but so now
stitch fix i was definitely skeptical at
first because i was like i just i always
want to have a signature style i always
want to be a little off i always want to
be a little weird i don't like dressing
how everybody else dresses and stitch
fix you took the quiz for me benton i
don't know what you said but everything
they send is either like for me per i
like really classic
like audrey hepburn meets catherine
hepburn and then just
totally
yeah loud isn't it like audrey hepburn
and a clown nose yeah that's right i
like i like clothes that are
um
just uh loud isn't the word fun fun yeah
you want people to walk up and go that's
fine i want people to be like oh that's
like an art teacher in albuquerque i
love her you know well stitch fix
freestyle is your trusted style
destination where you can discover and
instantly buy curated items based on
your style likes and lifestyle look at
these pants can i tell you and here's
what i love about stitch fix is like my
brain i'm such a creature of habit
that there's certain things i would
never think to buy even if i saw them in
the store because i'm like i just don't
know what i would do with those right
but like these these are eggplant purple
pants love i should wear these to every
like stand-up show yeah they're great so
whether you're looking for a brand you
love or you want to try a new one stitch
fix freestyle you can shop a range of
over a thousand brands personalized to
your size and fit but you're not just
like going on ten different websites
where it's like you have to put in your
credit card information and then you
have to like wait for it and then you
can't return it like this is just stylus
is taking your quiz and then curating
the box for you yes plus there's no
subscription required so nice or
subscription and they offer free
shipping returns and exchanges genius
get started today by filling out your
style quiz at stitchfix.com
whitney that's stitchfix.com whitney to
try
stitchfixfreestyle
stitchfix.comslashwhitney
we love it
we love it so come see us on tour
wearing my fancy stitch fix we are doing
40 more cities we are doing uh stand up
in every city for the next 40
weekends we're doing 40 more shows i
mean until april yeah and if you if you
sell them all out we'll stitch ourselves
together
we already are stitched together we need
to be surgically removed at this point
but come whitneycomings.com i'm not
going to blow up my instagram feed and
my twitter with stand-up stuff you know
all new hour
no politics we don't talk about politics
at all we do meet and greets afterwards
for free there's no charge for a vip
come get merch that stitch fix would not
dare sell or suggest to their
stitchers but you can buy we will sign
everything posters books whitney dvds
reciting boobs or signing abs or signing
butts so come see us on the touch me
tour and speaking of someone that i want
to touch back to christina ricci
so
in yellowjackets okay so i okay so
yellowjackets
is this is my favorite
thing
human nature when good people do bad
things because our reptilian brains take
over and it's about survival yes and
when all the cultural moires are dropped
because it's mere you bitch yeah
so i
don't want to give anything away but is
there anything
is there anything that you feel like you
like
learned making the show because it is so
um
we can't say savage anymore
uh why not what's wrong with savage well
savage i think calling someone a savage
the original
oh etymology of native americans yeah i
was just thinking in terms of animals i
know okay we don't it's like it's one of
those things you accidentally are like
oh right that was the thing that
was used to yeah degrade people didn't
know that right
but that's like
the word i wanted to say to describe
um brutal like the brutality of the show
but also the the
it's so funny
it is so funny good i mean i it's hard
for me because i'm close to it but i
believe you okay it's it's
you and juliet lewis
first of all already
brain explode
but
that character that you're playing
how
was she like how much of that
was on the page
well she's
written um can we first can i first say
the conceit of the show yeah please um
basically it's a uh soccer team in the
90s a very very successful uh uh
soccer team that's high school high
school girls that's doing really well
winning all the things is going to go
play
championships it's like a i think it's a
national championship somewhere so they
have to take private planes they get a
private plane plane crashes in the
middle of
i believe it's supposed to be northern
canada i thought so too okay northern
canada crashes
they're stranded
you know
and there's like a supernatural element
to where they crash where they crash so
it's
and
yeah a lot of board of the fly yes and
then there's a like the right amount of
mental illness amongst the girls
and also the supernatural element of
where they crash
and just enough that things go really
crazy really crazy lord of the flies
ain't shit
compared to the show yes yeah and they
yeah they do
terrible things and uh the so so we see
the characters in the 90s and then you
play a character um later and it
she's so funny
yeah
i mean you're so funny
she is
i mean she's fun to play um i don't love
again because i don't like people liking
me i actually don't like playing comedy
everybody on the show was always like
you're so funny and i was like i wasn't
trying to be funny um
okay
yeah exactly like a jerk
um
but
yeah that kind of the the point of her
character is very much like i always
describe myself as like a i'm like a
murderous golden retriever where it's
like
if you see a golden retriever you could
pet it love it immediately assume it's
going to be nice to you but what if that
golden retriever actually wanted to kill
you yeah and so that is sort of the idea
of misty the character where she's like
completely innocuous seeming
um but
horrible horrible desires inside of her
but there's an innocence to her that it
felt so real just the idea of like
like this person who has
you know her morals in the right place
but is like
i think that
most psychopaths do you think she's a
psychopath or sociopath i think she
started out and there's something off
about her
maybe a little sociopathy or sociopathy
sorry where she can't quite connect or
or um
she doesn't quite have the same
experience that everybody else does but
of course that leads to her wanting to
belong so badly and have the same
experience everyone else is having
because she's aware of the fact she's
not having it
um but then because she has no social
currency she's not cute she can't
connect so she can't like make jokes
that other people appreciate and
she can't really be part of the group
and you know what that would hap what
would happen to you in school and she's
just rejected time and time again
and then i think
after they get back from
once they're rescued i think she really
goes back to having no power no place no
value and after 25 years of this she has
created her own
um
her own satisfying world with her own
rules and what i like about her caligula
she does what i like about her is like
even though nobody's nice to her and
nobody's her friend she's still gonna
have the best time she can no matter
where she's entertaining herself she
doesn't need another person to talk to
really um
you don't like her jokes too bad she's
gonna laugh at them
um
and i but i think that she's living her
best life yeah and she realizes nobody's
gonna be nice to her nobody's going to
give her what she's always wanted so
she's going to give it to herself so
that involves a lot of manipulating
forcing and tricking
and she feels justified because if they
would have given it to her and begin
with she wouldn't have had to do this
i'm all i've just this is i'm doing what
i had to do yeah and i think that you
know it's interesting because when uh
serial killers and psychopaths that have
murdered
i'm gonna talk for a minute so you can
hydrate um
are interviewed
they don't say like i murdered that
woman they say it more as if they solved
a problem uh-huh you know so it's more
like well i had to kill her she was
screaming
yeah it was like i just had to stop the
so i had to kill her i didn't want to
kill her but she was screaming making
too much noise you know what i mean it
was like i did this horrible thing just
to solve this problem
that i had
and
in a way there's like a benevolence to
um
behind the horrific deed of like you
know when i don't think i'm spoiling the
show but when she she has to do
something like just to chop someone's
limb off it's like
someone has to do it yes i'm just gonna
do it because or else this person will
die yeah i have to kill this person so
they don't die
yes she's very practical i have to harm
myself
i have to traumatize this person so they
don't die like what what do we do
there's like a immediate ability to like
prioritize and that's slightly
sociopathic that is kind of common sense
in a way yeah and there's something so
funny about how not emotional yeah she's
just not very emotional about that kind
of thing and she wants what she wants
and will take whatever steps and doesn't
really understand why anyone else would
care like watching there's a scene where
uh you're on a date uh misty's on a date
with this guy and i learned so much from
this character's
exchange it was just like do you want to
go home later what did you not like me
you're not attracted to me
like if we could all just be that direct
we would save so much time but i also
think with her she's at a place where
she knows nobody's gonna like her fall
in love with her and she's almost
playing games when she does those kinds
of things it's like you know men like
well not all men but some men it's like
can you get that girl to sleep with you
i think misty sort of like i wonder if i
can get this guy to sleep with me
i know he doesn't want to but can i win
like this is just a game to me now yeah
like i'll just play
like play with you the way that you play
with women yeah well because i think
she's just bored and people have never
been nice to her and so she's
entertained herself and she's so
thrilled when all this bad stuff starts
happening again i love that and i love
you know because it reminded me of i'm
in this like place where you know
look i don't want bad things to happen
to anyone um the last couple years have
been you know wild uh for everyone but
like you know
i lost my dad
i
am just turned 39 like i've been through
a lot i've had a lot of family
heartbreak and there's kind of this
excitement in relationships now with
like
this fearlessness and freedom
when you can't get your heart broken
because it's already
so broke that there's nowhere to go like
you can't you're invincible yeah there's
a fun of like what are you gonna do
break my heart
you could actually start having fun
dating like what did you break the
shards of broken glass that are of my
heart like go for it like there's yeah
like i looked at her and i i just locked
i loved that like playfulness like
there's nothing to lose she doesn't i'm
going to date and like i'm going to make
this fun for me whether i what nothing i
can do is going to make you like me
because all you do is probably watch
porn and you probably want that sports
you know what i mean it is nice to be in
that place yes there's a certain freedom
of it yeah you know it's like i'm not
gonna let this be a waste of my time
yeah and i'm gonna have fun no matter
what i'm gonna have fun no matter what
and i'm not gonna like give you all my
power yeah and i really i've always
loved characters like that i love people
like that my mother's very much like
that
no matter what's happening we're going
to have a good time
like we're just like i don't you're not
i'm not going to allow this contagion to
get to me yeah like i'm having a blast
but i do think that comes from just
being really like
used to things being shitty
what is the deal with people that have
birds as someone i don't know but the
bird was
the i believe the bird was actually my
suggestion because i was like you know
like weird people who have birds dude
what's up
i don't really know i mean i will say
that having worked with a few birds now
they are kind of sweet
um they can be really affectionate i
would not have birds because i don't
like
the idea of something that just
drops poop everywhere
um
but that's pretty much it have another
baby
eventually they stopped and they were
diapers that's a very good point
um so i just tried to google why would
anyone have a bird
why do they have birds why would anyone
tell us why would anyone
company um
let me know when uh
i don't really like the idea of keeping
anything in a cage either
yes i think there's something a little
creepy about that why would anyone
have a
bird
it's wild because um i like them outside
i like the idea that you can keep them
around yeah eagles like owls i'm very
i'm obsessed with owls are you going to
put up an owl nest thing
yes yes and i want them to come live
here but i don't want to like have them
on my arm no like i don't like them i
don't like the idea of trapping anything
why would anyone want a bird i hope
google just birds are extremely what's
wrong with you
did you mean betty ford birds are
extremely intelligent easy to train and
social being intelligent makes birds
easier to train
than other animals since they are so
smart they're interesting to watch i
feel like a bird person wrote this
definitely i feel like a bird
a bird pecked this out on wikipedia
being intelligent the birds like birds
are so cool
peck this out look being intelligent
makes birds easier to train comma than
other animals
period
that's not
english no that bird wrote that so emily
that's bird i'm very obsessed with
vultures but emily what are you going to
tell us about there was a vulture in my
neighborhood
what dine there it was my agent
it was on the um
you know the telephone pole thingamajig
amazing can't stop saying
i'm sorry i love that i hate it let's
bring it back ugh um
i
love vultures because there's an amazing
ted talk this woman um
uh and she's from texas uh somewhere and
she uses vultures to solve crimes
because vultures oh the zest
so excited to say this
she so if someone's dead in the woods
and there's vultures
right because there are scavengers they
can only eat things that have already
been dead they basically rely on other
things dying and why is that um because
they're not hunters they don't have the
the the way hawks and eagles and falcons
have like
they can see two miles away right they
can't hunt got it they've just evolved
to just be scavengers they have the
leftovers which is actually used to be
very
uh
useful because so much was left because
humans we couldn't even open the bones
up and then we'd get all the marrow
because that's where all the real good
stuff is that's why their their vultures
brains are so big and that's how our
brains evolved was to eating the bone
marrow right you know the first things
vultures eat
the heart the eyes and the butthole
mm-hmm because they're the softest
tissue to get into the body yes so if
they know they're going to be
if it's already done so but if
so vultures because they have to be
economical
with what they eat
uh and they only you know they could not
eat for another month whatever the most
nutritious things are brains and
intestines those are the most nutritious
the the highest value so if there is a
vulture feather
30 feet away
from the corpse it was probably a
gunshot wound
because it meant the brain oh what was
over there oh that's interesting yeah so
they can narrow it down to wherever the
vulture feathers are yeah will tell you
what the where the brain went that's so
yeah isn't that neat yeah that is really
cool so cool
i'm obsessed
um emily yes uh emily has a lot to say
about crows
what about chris
crows are just the smartest animal other
than like the smartest non-primate
animal right don't they recognize
people's faces they recognize people's
faces they hold grudges yep they
like celebrate their dead they bring
like how do they celebrate they bring
candy wrappers they just pictured it
they bring dancing they bring candy
wrappers to the bodies of their dead
brethren they also try to have sex with
them which is not very smart but
they some humans do that too they are
okay and i can't ever say this properly
and i get a lot of flack for it but at
the stage of their evolution
when we were at the equivalent stage of
human evolution
the tools they're using are more
advanced than ours were
so like by the time they catch up to us
they're gonna be like
way more advanced but will they be able
to since they just have two legs and
beaks well i don't know we just had two
legs at one point
i see what you mean i'm bum we'll never
see it we have two legs now
i mean some of us um crows and ravens
are some of the smartest animals in the
world they control packs of wolves did i
ever say that i'm very excited about
that
okay so i love that someone had to
google why people want birds and now
we're all like have you heard about
birds
whoa crows and ravens are some of the
smartest animals in the world with their
intelligence considered on par with
chimpanzees the new
caledonian crow monkeys
i hate
i just hate them that's because you know
yeah they can get you yeah
they can rip your face clear up baby
monkey that almost ripped my boob off
once of course
i was just like and i had been talking
about how much i hated monkeys before
and everyone said it was my fault she
was the monkey could feel the machine
do you remember anything to the monkey
it was a scene and the monkey leapt over
and hung off my boobs what movie is this
that monkey's canceled
i know
you're like well it's because you have
such a bad attitude about monkeys i was
like
i mean come on i feel like
yeah this is a you thing
are you saying it's not you it's me
that's not my fault
but
i don't like them and i had to hold a
lot of them when i was younger because
all they know because the animal
trainers at on movies
would always have a monkey with them for
some totally bizarre reason and then
they'd be like get laid take a picture
with my monkey and as the child actress
you'd have to be like okay that's so
great this monkey and they just would be
so full of like
just like you could tell they were like
seething and they hated you and they
were their hands are so strong
i found it to be really upsetting and
then there were all the stories later
about people having things ripped off by
monkeys that they were rescuing and
stuff yeah what i mean yes and then when
it was by that trainer so they were
pissed right anyone be there yeah it's
just too
much
it's too much yeah
well look i did tell you about have i
talked about how a very famous magician
david copperfield no
sent me a video yes okay
training crows
yeah and he was it was like a he was
training the crows to pick up a card
based on what the card was
it was like king of hearts and it would
go get the king of hearts like from a
deck of cards
well you know those crows are holding a
garage now
i mean that's that is wild yeah
why did he send you a video of this
look it's a jungle out there
yeah we're training it raya raya wasn't
up yet
okay bumble wasn't popping yet okay we
had to do what we had to do to get by
we had to meet weirdos the old-fashioned
way
i remember when he used to do magic at
balthazar in 1997.
that's so that he started in new york
doing that like street magic experience
we would go to clubs and stuff there all
of a sudden they were like magicians
that would come to your table
and we'd give them really hard times
really hard times
it's so fascinating like i in comedy
there's so many people that i sort of
started with that i'm like
that
for whatever reason they're not doing it
anymore or
they're
um didn't have what get what i think
they should have gotten for whatever
reason the universe etc but is there
anyone they were like
i just what happened to that person like
there's certain comments where i'm like
what happened to that guy and i'll
follow up with them and they're like oh
i just you know i became a banker and
whatever and i just there are people but
i don't know how to get in touch with
them so interesting
interesting
yeah is there anyone that um
you feel like you've been like
consistently grown with like
and been like i see you and have grown
together and been cool with like it's
yeah i mean there's lots of people that
i feel like we all were around at the
same time and came up in the same kind
of like group of people
you know like um
i don't know we were all
young but around the same time like
kirsten dunst i've known her since she
was three i think i met her at an
audition i was six or seven
i was seven she was probably three or
four it's wild and i remembered this
child forever she was we before she
became a famous actress my mother and i
used to refer to her as that gorgeous
little girl with the beautiful hair
because she was like this charming
gorgeous little girl that i was had
these beautiful curls and i don't know
it's like what hitler wanted i know it's
weird but as a seven-year-old i was
obsessed with her and then she became an
actress and i was like oh my god it's
that girl
i get it she's just got that star
quality really
yes
i just watched the britney murphy
documentary i did too
it was weird
it's weird
i don't know what to believe
i mean that guy i had seen him right he
had done a lot of really shady
disgusting things like it
we knew he was bad news you know just
but ultimately
it's not a big
it's not the death that is the
scandalous thing it's the way he used
her right because really they just
didn't go to the doctor they were doing
too many drugs
right yeah and then and then when
like who knows how long it took them to
call the police because they were
worried that right right and then he
died of the same thing because he was
just living the same life that they had
been living yeah so it's not like a huge
mystery or um
or a conspiracy
that he died
of the same exact thing
right it's just i got from it pisses me
off yes it's very unfortunate and
that someone's desire to be happy and
have a family and have a life and all
these things and be loved and lead them
right into the lion's den is really
unfortunate but it is just wild because
it is you know we were talking
downstairs earlier about like just like
seeing i want to be the person that
gets hurt every now and then but sees
the best in people i'd rather just be
that person i'd rather be the person
that it's like you know like believes in
someone it gets my heart broken i don't
want to be the person that's always
assuming the worst and cynical and you
know i just don't want to live that way
you know and um
and
it was it's weird because like amazing
actors i think have this
antenna
uh this incredibly hyper sensitivity
that's that's incredible like i directed
a movie and i had no idea what i was
doing
and um i literally they i wrote the
script with neil brennan who co-created
the chappelle show and they were like
we'll only make it if you direct it and
i was like
okay i know what i was doing i went home
i went on youtube and went like how do i
direct a movie like direct a movie
question mark
and like
moviephone.com
and christopher nolan
uh was like giving these like to camera
like bts interview things and he said
in one of them uh
you cannot lie to an actor
because they'll know because it's their
they their their bullshit detector is
like no other like good actors you so if
you need to
you know move a scene because you're
losing light and you're running out of
money or there's a problem with the crew
or there's like a union issue you can't
be like hey we're actually gonna do over
here now because i just i feel like the
character would like be having tea
they're gonna be like they're gonna stop
trusting you no yeah and you're gonna
lose the trust of that they're just make
sense don't treat them like children
right just say hey we're losing light
i'm running out of time oh it's a good
idea we have to compromise
it's going to be just as good but what
we rehearsed is not going to happen
whatever we couldn't get the monkey
because christina was too mean to it
christina was so mean to the monkey that
we don't have a monkey so now we're
going to use a squirrel that's what
we're doing yeah and um
and that squirrels also though murderous
[Laughter]
that does remind me though sarah
silverman had that joke in one of the
specials about how
squirrels when they they they're dumb so
they plant their nuts and then that's
and they
eat later and they forget where they are
and that's how trees grow
oh
i mean good for trees
i guess are they dumb or really
conscious about the earth well i had it
i've been
not to
go away from the chris nolan thing
please don't get back to
from
um
but i watched that you know they are um
what is it omnivo i'm omnivorous they
are omnivorous they will eat whatever
they can and because they have such a
large food supply in places like
southern california because there's no
winter
they become bigger than other rodents
and so then they eat other rodents so in
my backyard
i watched a squirrel once throw a rat
out of a tree the rat was like
like broke its back or whatever the
squirrel came down grabbed it took it up
onto a branch and ate it while it was
still alive
i'm not kidding
it happened and that is what we call a
bummer
yeah and the squirrels are territorial
so this one squirrel still lives in my
backyard and i hate it and it will like
scream at me they also try to intimidate
me
they don't spark like the noise they
make is like as they bark like a dog
yeah they it's really weird this girl
would try to intimidate me and scare me
away from like i have i had a place in
my backyard where i like to go and i
would like meditate and talk to the
animals and the squirrel would be like
go fuck yourself i'm bigger than you but
yes i don't like them very much
i mean squirrels are kind of arrogant
because they are kind of just like fancy
rats
they're rats with a and everybody thinks
they're cute i know they get more credit
than they deserve i agree yes yep anyway
so chris nolan said you can't lie to
actors because their antenna is so
accurate some squirrels fly
that's true i enjoy a flying squirrel
like that's special also
no it is also we under use the word he's
a little bit squirrely it's true i like
squarely it's a great way to describe
someone that's like shifty or shady or
sketchy squirrely yep
it's like that obviously means swirls
are sketchy because that's why we have
that as an adjective yeah they're
definitely sketchy no but i was yeah i
was just thinking about it i was like
brittany murphy was such a good actress
like how did you not
feel how tall ro off that was you know
what i mean you think that her desire
over definitely clouded yes i feel like
i've made a lot of mistakes um and
characters yeah they're doing those
problems
i have misjudged a lot of people and i
think it's just that you want so badly
for something to
be what you want it to be and to work
out that you ignore yes and you also
minimize you're like well how bad could
it be
how about really how bad could this get
and i can fix this or i can't put up
with that and i've already been i've
already put a year into it yes and as
women it's like i only have three years
left to have kids so i'll just it's fine
you assume that things can't be worse
than what you've already gone through
as someone that has that's true an
incredible like antenna
intuition got like what would you say
are some red flags in people like to
date in dating
um
i think any time people have outsized
reactions to things
whoa
you know like if someone gets too angry
about something that
you're pretty sure it wasn't a big deal
that's
such a good one yeah i used to when i
was dating i would have these moments
where i'd be sitting across from someone
and i'd be like
this is when i should get up and leave
this is it right now
and i used to have this joke about um
the this elf that you could like a
whistle and like an elf don't know if it
was more like a troll that you could it
was the emotionally unsafe elf
that anytime you felt emotionally unsafe
but you were not able to stand up for
yourself you could summon this elf that
would show up and just like yeah no that
that that's a no is not okay and we are
going home young lady
like peter dinklage just comes up with i
mean
yeah
and so i've had so many moments like
that where i was like where i've been
like yeah i know that this is when i
should blow the whistle and get like sub
and someone to come and like pick me up
or i should go home but i had this weird
thing in me i think that was really when
i was younger like
is is this really happening what else is
gonna happen yeah
like a weird such a separation from
myself that i was able to stand across
the room and be like but i kind of want
to see what happens i wanted to i'd like
a little bit of like a
i mean i
you know was addicted to adrenaline i
was like great let's go through this
haunted house great yeah and i just
think too i had trouble actually feeling
the reality of things
like i would sort of
numb yourself i didn't feel it yeah i
was so able to be all of a sudden across
the room watching it that like if you
don't actually feel upset it's hard to
take action
do you know you can like disassociate
yeah
i can do that but why
i think it's from childhood drama
correct yeah
yeah pretty much so yeah i've always
been like that so there was this part of
me that was like oh wait but this is so
fascinating yeah but now i'm over here
like and i'm safe yeah but i gotta watch
this show this
it's just a is tv show
which is really
interesting i can't leave now it's just
getting good yeah and i think it takes a
while i think if you're like that you
have to get to a place where you're like
okay the consequences of this ultimately
this doesn't end well so i know how this
story is let's not watch this show we're
going to see this we're going to be up
all night we won't be able to sleep
let's turn this off
and you're married
yes i am i'm so happy for you thank you
i actually met with someone really
fantastic so i mean your hair looks i'm
so jealous you're married to someone
that does hair like yeah
life hack if you have bangs
the only way to have cute bangs
is to marry someone that can bang you
yeah you know what
it helps me get aroused what death
and that brings the liquid
so i'm gonna be very honest with you
i
oh
i know this never goes well
a couple years ago a friend of mine
sophia omoroso she's girl boss she wrote
the girl boss book
netflix show netflix show girl boss she
sent me a text and was like you gotta
invest in this company liquid death and
she sent me a picture of the can it's
it's water in this gorgeous can with
this gold skull on it it's like me in a
can
and she's like you gotta invest in this
company it was before i knew how to
invest it was before i like had the
money to invest i was like yeah i'd love
to but i don't i don't even know what
you're talking about i was like can i
buy that and she's like no no you want
to invest in the company i was like
i will buy that please send it to me
like i didn't understand what it how
investing worked yet so i'm the idiot
that didn't invest in liquid death
i'm the idiot that i don't let you do it
now
i don't i feel like that ship is sailed
i mean whatever do you feel like your
grandpa my grandfather passed on
investing in mcdonald's when the he
would have only it would have only cost
him 200 to have something like 5 000
shares and so thank god we wouldn't be
here liquid death is the one that got
away from me because i did not know
about investing at the time and it is
now
i mean if you don't have if you're not
drinking this water you're just
a loser
it's like i love it i like that they
look like strange tall boys of beer
you can drink them at a party and stuff
and nobody's like human beings
well that's the thing also this is the
new sparkling one i don't know yeah i
bought this yet i bought this yesterday
and it when you buy it like you go get
it everyone's like what's that like it's
it's i'm trying to think it's like it's
like the drink equivalent of like riding
a motorcycle or like having a cool
tattoo and now it's like theovan segura
burt everyone's got this you know
it's
it's just like
it just makes me feel cool i know that's
a dorky thing to say straight
mountain spring water also i love the
stories like if you follow them on
instagram and stuff there's all these
stories people send in about them being
pulled over and please thinking it's a
beer or like getting carded when they
buy it like it's just really it's two
punk rocks and the marketing is like so
trolly they're just like such a fun
company i also by the way we're three
people that hate water we do not drink
water enough and i'm i'm sorry i know
this is maybe childish but i cannot
drink a water if it's a cool bottle like
this makes it makes you want a shotgun
it makes me want to drink water like it
just makes me feel cool uh and why is it
called liquid death because it will
brutally murder your thirst love and
their infinitely recyclable tallway cans
are helping to bring death
to plastic bottles and guilt they also
donate 10 of their profits from every
can to help kill plastic pollution which
is freaking awesome so get free shipping
on all water and merch at liquid death
dot com slash whitney that's liquid
death dot com slash whitney or grab some
at whole foods sprouts oh and 7 11.
that's killer
back to christina
but so is there any so he's a hairstyle
is there and is it ever is he ever not
thinking about your hair or is it well
that's the thing he doesn't really think
about it unless i asked him ask him
about it oh he's not that kind of person
but he's really fantastic and he has
built he builds things in the house and
he actually so
he sewed a lot of my child's halloween
costume this year come on he cut his
hair into a mohawk and does his hair
does
makes my son's hair a mohawk every day
before school
yeah that is the cue it's really really
wonderful
and when since we're pregnant like he
just does everything for me it's really
horrible horrible i feel
so bad
[Music]
hi guys
so this is hi
john legend and uh
oh my god it's the original
christie hi i saw pictures of you this
wednesday you looked great
they dressed up as wednesday adam i know
i saw pictures
everybody looked fantastic
she yes unrehearsed but she was like she
knew at that moment
and it works very well
so cute
yeah where are you guys going
christina this is chrissy hi hi
we met a long time ago at somebody's
party once
years and years ago
we're driving the kids home from school
oh yeah
christina's pregnant
nine months congratulations
thank you
thank you so much how far along i'm 34
weeks today oh my gosh that's like
tomorrow you're gonna have a baby
i wish that i asked my doctor if he
would take mine out earlier and he said
no do it at 38 then you won't rip washi
i still ripped incredibly i'm having a
c-section so
i'm just having a c-section and we're
gonna just it's gonna be fine
oh my gosh so cute
we love you
[Applause]
i love you i love you i love you bye
um
i feel like i hung up too soon
was that too bad she was like i think
you're and i'm done i used you
why do you think there's i don't want to
ask you about adam's family because it's
like i just feel like your life is no
it's fine it's it's more like why do you
think it's
becoming
in the zeitgeist again
um well i mean they made animated movies
out of it so all the kids know about it
but ah
i see okay okay because i i do find
though that like our generation like the
things that we
were into in the 90s are kind of coming
back yeah there's a lot of 90s because
like we have
like i mean i'm wearing a betsy johnson
dress like it i cut it what about you
cut it um and uh
i have a wednesday adam story from
childhood oh really do tell i sure do
i
was a big fan
of wednesday adam's and
once in the fifth grade in perry county
tennessee
yes in perry county tennessee my small
town we were at pe class and i kept
tying all the jump ropes into nooses
like she had that in the film and uh
i was under the bleachers and i was just
hanging all these nooses under the
bleachers of the jump ropes
and my teacher came around and she was
like what are you doing but i didn't
hear her and so i was like i was doing
slipknots yeah yeah so i just kept tying
them and she was apparently yelling at
me to like come talk to her but i just
couldn't hear it was like recess i was
just making my nooses in peace and um
she got very distraught called my
parents and i had to go to
four weeks of therapy because i thought
i was going to kill myself oh no and
they had the preacher come and tell me
that uh wednesday adams and and the
osborne's and all these things were evil
and then i couldn't partake in them
anymore oh no which didn't stick but
yeah
that's a really harsh punishment for
just tying some nuts well
i was pretty excited about it
i was like this is what happened to
wednesday adam's too
that's a good story
yeah it is
it was better in my hand but
it didn't happen it is interesting when
like things get super relevant again
like the the i think maybe it's just
more our desire for nostalgia or
something
yeah i don't know you're getting so
weird and and modern that we're like i'm
gonna go back to the thing that you know
that like makes you feel safe yeah
totally yeah i don't know my son was
really into the adam family also and i
know it doesn't have anything to do with
me being involved do we know what your
next baby is
yeah okay don't feel the need i can't
decide if i should or not don't don't
then don't okay but can we do
can i guess the names yeah sure i've
guessed
two friends names exactly baby names
exactly okay you know what i'm having a
girl who gives a shit
i can't i can't do the whole like
i don't know but at least you're not the
person that's like i want to be
surprised no i have enough surprises in
my life
i don't need that one
also like i don't want to i don't want
i need to buy you a present you need to
tell me that i don't want my thing i'm
like i need to i have to plan i don't
want to come hang out in your yellow
baby room i hate the color yellow or the
moss green because you didn't want to do
pink or blue i'm okay with green though
a pistachio green pistachio green i like
it like an adult like just let me i need
to know what to buy your child just tell
me find out this isn't about you no i
feel the same way but i i just want to
know what happened when you heard you're
having a girl i was really excited
because i already have a boy so cool so
yeah i figured would be good already a
bodyguard
okay so can i do
let's go i already have so many crazy
things where i'm like yeah she's never
having one of those and guess what we're
not like halloween came and i was like
like i'm ever going to allow my child to
do slutty halloween like what if that's
my face
but i was like i will ruin that no baby
will ever be as cute as kirsten dunst
you should dress her up soon
can i interview the
vampire she could be a vampire i'd be
cute um
it's interesting i mean emily you know a
lot about this like the toxic like
princesses and this and that it's sort
of like she can be a princess if she
wants to as long as it's everything
even the barbie thing where now they
have like plus-sized barbie it's like
didn't we all just accept that barbie is
bad
why are we trying to mitigate this this
is party pooper exactly party pooper
this podcast is a hit i'm telling you
this package is a hit
and it was so weird to me when i saw
other people's children with barbies
like in 2020 and i was like wait i
thought
we all came to the conclusions this is
terrible but also mine were plus size
because i microwaved them
oh yeah they were huge i didn't know
that they were bubbling they had
cellulite spiders we used to give them
weird haircuts and set them on fire yeah
totally yeah so it's like that is
i don't know i'm not a mom so i never
want to like weigh in on stuff i don't
understand but um but i am that person
too like with the new james bond thing
when they're like james bond needs to be
a woman i'm like
does it
let's just create a new character that
um doesn't have its core in misogyny and
and sexually like really sexualizing
women because you know what's happening
behind the scenes is that the men that
made these
characters they're just going to get
more money when you remake it yeah yeah
they just get the licensing fee you know
why we can't move on to new stuff just
bring a new thing yes that's fine yeah
you know and then have the woman that
writes it and directs it and creates it
have them get the money
yeah because now they're going to get
less money because the guys that came up
with the idea are going to get the
results
like the big trick the trick that's been
played on all of us that feminism just
means like getting to own and sexually
exploiting yourself yeah like what
yeah you're a feminist now you get to be
naked all the time talk about how much
you want to have sex on your turn
do you think that people are scared to
make new characters and new id concepts
because there's so many quote-unquote
rules to follow now they're scared of
getting it wrong so they're like oh we
can just take this thing that already
has fans well people like a shirt and
get the bonus points for doing something
yeah it's like
we can't we already have coke let's just
make it coke plus instead of a new
new brand that's not known imagine we
wouldn't have dr pepper we wouldn't have
the prune prune flavored beverage
if they had stuck to that i'm sorry i
have a pepper obsession wait i'm
obsessed with dr pepper it's prune
flavored
what yeah
benton i mean i know it has 23 flavors
right i thought it's supposed to be a
prune flavored soda don't ruin this for
me oh i don't know i didn't know that i
thought it was cupcake it was supposed
to be a cupcake it's my favorite
drink yeah like dr pepper mm-hmm yeah i
always thought it was like a
prune i believe it's prune flavored it
does it kind of tastes like figs too
yeah like dried figs
my favorite fruit
by the princess
okay what's your baby's name okay let me
just
let me just do this
let's just bounce so you have in your
head like five names nope one one only
you're done you've agreed on it i like
to make a decision and stick to it early
on i get a lot of anxiety about things
that i haven't been decided upon
pearl
no but you're close
i'm telling you it's a gift
okay and how am i close am i like what's
close to a pig
it's an emerald i think you're close in
style of name okay yes yes yes yes yes
harriet
no
okay good so now i know i'm in the um
ruby huh ruby no but i like that name
but i had a dog named ruby in my
childhood so do it so that see see
that's the thing if i knew her better i
would have knocked that out already so
my i have a friend no don't be have you
you are so sorry that was so awful i
have a friend who has a baby named ruby
that i guessed right ruby is really cute
but i know that she wasn't going to do
another one because she had a dog named
a cat in them
um okay i'm close in style
interesting and where are you from new
jersey yep kind of
do you go back no
snooki
do you go to
where is your favorite place to vacation
if you just had a month off
oh i would either go to europe or mexico
where in mexico
i've only been to one place in mexico
punta jamita
and then what's your favorite movie like
couple
like
just your favorite like off the top of
my head i would say audition is one of
my favorite movies wow um
and i love um let's see audition
um
12 monkeys that's one of my favorite
movies but you hate monkeys
yeah but they don't really play a huge
part in that movie here's the other
thing i forgot to pronounce it
remember the wizard of oz sequel
yes it was a great movie the monkeys on
wheels who is the buck
oh and all the headless all the heads
yeah that's a great scene but remember
with all the the monkeys had
wheels yeah
because monkeys are evil well we are
monkeys all good
monkeys but that's the problem they're
like less
evolved humans that's right and that is
the issue and that's why they're bad
it's we are um
uh
bonobo apes
and humans
have closer genetic code than african
elephants and indian elephants
i know i mean we're monkeys
um
is what's your mom's name sarah
cute what's your middle name i don't
have one
my mother didn't give any of us middle
names
what's the point of a middle name well
that's what she felt she felt it was
purely religious and she was her like a
few to the system i love her i enjoy
things like that about her
she's just fun
um
what was your what's your dog's name
which one both what are their names
what are their names i have karen
carpenter i have patrick
i have logan and magneto what's uh
logan is a pit lab mix we think and
what's logan from logan is from an
adopted from my stand with my pack
uh
i work with them yeah i'm on their board
what
i don't know how helpful i am but i'm on
the board oh my god they asked me to be
on the board and i was like i need to
deal with this dog thing
let's do oh my god yeah be bored buddies
yeah
um it's like the only rescue that i've
messed with i love them because i have
two dogs from them
yeah oh my god that makes me so happy
yeah that member um violet was i stand
with my pack um yeah that's the one with
the big ears um
yeah i made all the sharpies
hmm i love shark base i love sharpies i
love sharp paste they're fascinating
they are fascinating that's right it's
so small and they kept staring at you
yeah violently yeah she had um antropic
like her she had been starved so
severely that her eyelids folded under
and we had to cut all of her eyelashes
out and then
her eyes are just like marbles staring
at you and in sharpies they're bred to
pick one person and they're just like
obsessed with you
no one else exists i know it's like a
nightmare for a co-dependent love addict
i'm like this is what it should be like
and like there's no life outside you
so the trick is when you're fostering a
rescue sharpay is like once they get
attached it's very hard like the first
time i brought her to a possible home to
be adopted
the door i left out of she
bit
she bit through the door
like
uh tore up her face
and then uh uh broke one of her ankles
because she tried to jump over a fence
to get to me it's like there's nothing
stopping them so then it was like okay
now another six months of like rehab and
surgery just because
yeah their nature is super intense but
they're also they were bred um
in asia to be fighting dogs that's why
they have all the wrinkles is to have uh
for blood to be able to drain off them
you know i know it's dark and to be able
to grab them and
just like when you put all of them back
yes i know i'm upset
and they're also not that soft if you if
you rub them one way they're really soft
and the other way it's like prickly yeah
you know they don't really want to be
petted they've evolved to not
ruth
no
can you tell me a couple that we're
runners-up
hold up
yeah sure
um i like gold
you know what goldie is a name i liked
my husband did not um
uh imogen
oh love
and i've always liked the name valentine
love
my husband did not enjoy that um
val it's val at the end of the day yeah
i guess so but
i don't know
anyway
i was attached to it um
and there were there really weren't that
many
to say the truth what were the runners
up of your son
there weren't any i just we i just
decided on freddy that was it that was
it
because i always i know it sounds really
dumb but i always kind of wanted to i
liked the idea of having a kitten named
freddie mercury
and um i never got that
so i just named my son after him
did you see the movie i did
thoughts
i
gave me anxiety to
watch him handle those teeth
yeah that's all i can look straight and
i and he's such a wonderful actor yeah i
just couldn't stop thinking of better
ways they could have done that like
you're just thinking about the time it
took to put like the fact that he was
like suffering yes yes
yes
that's all
but you know he wanted a word for
those teeth so
this is hard but i don't want you to
tell me the name because you want to
keep the name secret
i mean i don't know
when will this come out yes when will
this air it's airing currently oh next
week next week yeah
no i won't have had her yet mhm
nora
no but it is really you're really close
you're doing great
you're not going to go like silly you're
not going to do ethel too much
you know what i mean
you're not going to go silly goose
i like the name violet i love it i mean
that the violet was the name of my
sharpay yeah that's like i i always do
violet my dogs violet daisy tulip all
those
tulip
i even like the name pansy but you can't
really name the child tricky one it's
too hard it's a tricky one
but it's my favorite flower
pansy mm-hmm
i like a pansy yeah they're really
pretty
there are ironically we have very
resilient very resilient that's why i
like them
um
you know just like real-life pansies
very resilient this is annoying i'm
sorry
this is i feel like because i don't want
to say another one that's wrong
i'm going to text you tonight at like 2
a.m well i'll tell you i mean
i'll just tell you don't tell you're on
the show but after yeah tell me after
you yeah after
are your new middle name
uh we're doing my last name as a middle
name oh that's so sweet
now freddie's like why don't i have your
last name and middle name
oh um we can we can are you taking your
new husband's last name i'm not is that
a thing no i'm not is that even a thing
i feel like people still do it yeah i'm
not doing it but you're like bitch i'm
famous it's just it's a lot of paperwork
it's a lot of purple tunnel lazy
again i have i get so worried that i'm
going to screw up the paperwork or do
something wrong it's like i just want to
drive downtown i don't want to like
everything's fine yeah
things are good to ruin a good thing
and what's that can i ask the last name
hampton christina that's cute yeah he's
had a very nice name mark hampton it's a
nice name that is such a good name i
haven't met him though no you haven't
met him because i was like sometimes
with hair artists you've met him on
things and you know him well he's
british and so he mainly worked in
fashion and stuff so he's done celebrity
stuff but
mainly
fashion stuff smart
i met him years ago on a magazine cover
for netaporte
heaven
yeah
i could gaze into your eyes forever
i'm totally obsessed with you
i hope that when you have a baby
i still get to see you yes of course
well i learned something so when my
friend dory had a baby i didn't like
reach out to her at all because i was
like oh she's probably busy she has
babies she's not sleeping things are
crazy and i was talking to um
uh my therapist and i was like i just
haven't seen dorian i don't know if i'm
supposed to like she's not calling me i
don't do and she was like she has a
child
she wants to see adults
she wants to hang out with adults you go
over there and talk to her because she's
just talking to a ball of goo right now
like yeah you know what i mean so i just
thought that like oh when a woman has a
baby she probably doesn't want to
socialize she probably was in the time
she's exhausted and she's like no you
have to like go hang out with her i was
like oh i had no idea like i thought i
would be annoying or putting pressure on
her
no no you should come over to the house
maybe i'll just send you stuff on
postmates okay yeah that was
although fun
those juices were really good christina
was uh under the weather last week i was
like i'm gonna send her some juices on
postmates like you know
and then
the next day i ordered lunch
i was the default address
i just kept saying and they're like
sending me pictures like where's my food
it didn't come and they're sending me
photos of i guess your house and i was
like oh god i'm so sorry my weird like
quinoa
is at your door i really apologize i bet
that asshole squirrel got it no we took
it in okay yeah before the spring
sprinklers went out
it's so stupid
um yellowjackets i
can't i cannot explain how amazing this
show is no it's funny the music the
music's good and there's lots of like
it's very dark and brutal you know it's
like you know it's like a girl
it's like a woman our age who was
obsessed with
tarantino films as a teenager made this
show he's about to say it feels like
natural-born killers
today there's a brutal like a brutality
to it that is intentional because you
don't often see women
especially just like nora like i mean
melanie's character she's like a
stay-at-home mom who
like skins a rabbit for dinner just
because she gets angry mm-hmm you know
you don't see that very often so
it's fun yes and the character abuses
old people it's great
i'm ju but if there's a there's a um
grounded humanness in it
that is so it's not like bitches be
crazy it's made with like reverence like
women are capable of this shit too and
you shut like you squeeze a person you
know like this these people have all
been squeezed and these are the
personalities that come out of them when
you squeeze them for years and years and
years if you're gonna push me up against
a wall this is how i'm gonna retaliate
you know what i'm saying yeah like i
don't so it's cornered animals it's
exactly it's badass and not like oh this
is like gone girl drove me nuts i was
like oh this is okay this is what you
got you guys think women act like we
can't handle a breakup we're gonna just
have to go like kill everybody and
figure out what we don't never take it
from that point of view but yeah i see
that uh eunice
no
thank you this is
tough brutal that would be tough
yeah that's a believe in setting
challenges for my children adversity
builds character that is
okay
that's a tough one you know what i like
julep
julep is cute julep is cute
i like julie
i like julie yep it's very french
reminds me of it the julie andrews story
that i've told before on the podcast a
friend of mine asked for a photo with
julie andrews like he's famous he's like
the only person that was like famous to
him right and he was like i'm so sorry
like can i please get a photo i said no
no she said of course oh
goes take the photo and as they snap the
photo she goes
money
what does that mean
she does that that's what makes her
smile her face looks the best when she
says money like how the oil syndrome say
prune
the do you remember that's what you
would prove today
i don't know
no but that is just a coincidence but
remember when they had their resurgence
and they were always
and it came out that they say prune when
they take pictures prune
who does the late 90s else in twins oh
the ultimate
[Music]
which is funny to me because i feel like
you could say bunny or sunny or funny
anything yeah why money
i just think that's the stuff it's such
a power move
money nice to meet you what just
happened that's like such a gangster
move
it's pretty good ah i love you i am
these super awkwardly okay
and um yellow jackets
watch them yellow chickens watch out for
them
watch out for the media jickets showtime
showtime time and if it's on show time
does that mean it's on other things too
show time show time you know what else
is on show time your honor
i got your honor that show with brian
cranston like showtime is making the
shows yeah
yeah this is on after the new dexter
whoa so it's gonna be dexter and then
yellow jackets yeah that's huge showtime
is like like popping
yeah i'm excited about the new dexter
yeah that one
don't ride elephants we love you
that's how we end every podcast oh great
okay
[Music]
ah
[Applause]